c'est à l'arbalète que florence tente
d'abattre son premier chevreuil au début
c'est stressant mais ses cheveux c'est
le fun c'est comme l'adrénaline peut la
voir avec sa famille elle participe à la
fin de semaine de la relève organisé par
le ministère de la forêt de la fonde et
des parcs deux jours de chasse réservée
uniquement à la relève accompagné de
mentor qui lui n'a pas le droit de
chasser ces merveilleux soyeux downtown
chanson n'a qu'à s'occuper de l'autre
comme il faut aussi la une activité qui
a débuté en 2020 et qui gagne en
popularité
lors de la première édition je vous
rappelle 696 bien sûr participants en
pleine pandémie 1624 c'est sûr quand
même assez significatif on parle d'une
hausse extrêmement importante ici par
rapport à la première édition selon les
chiffres du ministère de la faune le
nombre de chasseurs est en constante
diminution au québec depuis 2013 cela
est dû notamment au vieillissement de la
population mais également en raison de
l'écotourisme qui changent notre rapport
à l'environnement et à la diminution de
la consommation de viande encouragés par
le mouvement vegan il se tue en moyenne
cinquante mille chevreuil chaque année
au québec sur un total de 325 mille
bêtes pour contrôler les populations la
chasse sportive fait partie de la
solution on est tellement détruit mais
c'est naturel en détruisant les
habitants la chasse effectué par
l'humain devient un mécanisme de
contrôle des populations le lieu d'être
au format sd qui est vraiment essentiel
pour maintenir en vie les cheptels mais
aussi pour éviter les dommages à
l'environnement
près des deux tiers des participants la
fin de semaine de la relève ont entre 12
et 17 ans ils espèrent tous abattre un
animal d'ici dimanche florence elle a
réussi elle a tué un mal à six pointes
en fin de journée tout comme sept autres
chasseurs de 14 ans ici marie josée
paquet comme radio-canada saint michel
des saints